Melvin game on Friday night you do in
the Melvin dead you know why you got so
much [ __ ]
I took enough criticism you can't leave
him can't leave oh well then it's
switching very well and somebody got
their signals crossed I mean the defense
was airtight
until somebody left Aaron Gordon for
whatever reason to look at this again
nice body control on that look at Aaron
Gordon shoulder to shoulder with boots
nowhere for J Michael Greene to go and
Evan puts it right where it needs to be
the tubes
trailed by quarter talents at the rim
twice
Williams travel is terrific interior
defense David about much of it
butcher knife deep in his body in there
on Newark ik- Flav the second one
enter a switch Isaac with the steel for
the magic ahead to Gordon he'll dump it
in what a nice job Jonathan Isaac shot
clock down to five
we said is at 14 or in Gordon with the
shot clock at one three threes tonight
for [ __ ] frost checks in
he's been the magic spark off the bench
offensively organ back door cut and
Gordon put it on the money season out of
bounds plays watch the screen by Jared
Graham gets a piece of Evans guy and
it's right to the rim good set up by
Evan think about Terrence is 51 point
game there's a steal by Jared
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
six out Aaron George
oh yeah taken away by DJ high-fliers
heron garden so three new starters three
rookies in that starting line Aaron
Gordon steamed points before today
looking for an opening bouncing off of
Hardaway Gordon with the ball puts it in
a tough shot by Hera watch on Aaron's
drive from your left-hand side of your
screen
Aaron's just go sneak in there under the
basket you have seven individually Oh
trovich comes to the ball nice feed mind
the head throw down about a G on the
back cut here terrific pass a little
something extra to take with you against
these teams the poor rebounding teams in
the league the Phoenix Suns just
overpowering a reason you mentioned his
defensive ability he is a good on the
ball defender but on developing being
get comfortable with the footwork
necessary to be a good three-point
shooter this summer
flying high for the dunk Aaron Gordon
lets it fly
that's no good rebound is planted to the
floor picked up by Augustine
Gordon through the backdoor Rockford
guarded by Gordon reason take it away by
Gordon he's got distance on the defender
to shut you will take the chances with
solutely Warner behind the screen got it
for three
[Music]
[Applause]
steal by Gordon he's off to the races
McGruder will not even attempt a mouth
ng showing that competitive side David
it knocks down the three gets the steal
and was his assessment they had to do a
better job on him to that point yep
[Music]
miraculous play by Gordon this one again
watch this move up and under the rim did
he kiss it off the glass if he did it
was a very slight kiss during the
two-minute mark in the fourth quarter
[Music]
[Applause]
the three-point line well but you gotta
get the threes off of drives more than
stops back down of it play by Aaron
Gordon first on the defenses in realize
I did magic oversight but Dante and
Galante they're been several Hall of
Fame's
[Applause]
down a bit Court
[Applause]
Derrick Jones jr. rejected by Aaron
Gordon
now let's go back and look at the block
by Aaron Jones a high riser again
contest champion not high enough there
that is a great block did a pretty good
job playing Evan Fournier off the Drive
just lost by Aaron Gordon this Sunday
afternoon at Central Florida for the
hometown Orlando Magic Man to grip the
ball good timing on that double team by
Ross that ball landed in the hands of
boots of engineer Alex player at Tulsa
of energy what a nice pass
[Applause]
offensively against Chicago the high
flyer Aaron Gordon a step back to show
many different ways tonight 14 points
eight assists and 7 rebounds for one
third by Jamie Toliver throws it away
Gordon splits two defenders and athletic
Aaron Gordon midway in the first quarter
they can away by Augustin a poor pass by
the rookie this was a great play by DJ
Augustin it's a great play by Aaron
Gordon but we've seen that so many guy
yeah we like to see here and get out and
run the floor but DJ with the confidence
to throw the bat and backing in knocked
away Aaron gets it back Aaron Jordan has
it going in this first half for the
magic a lot of opportunities Ross with
the steal at mid
[Applause]
to watch the great hands by Terrence
Ross kicking across the court of heaven
for da heads up Eric Gordon coming to
Rory
down the lane 48 that it back shot clock
at Fort Gordon came open at the last
second
[Music]
Burch with the paddling rebound Gordon
for three second chance free for the
magics Aaron Gordon they're terrific
hustle in there a minute to play in the
food
Gordon Aaron Gordon a little
miscommunication where the guys in white
real the worst Jam two steps maybe
behind the three-point with John Isaac
right there don't release what his range
is having four then another great play
in the half court for the banjo
[Music]
[Applause]
it's the brown skirt of us I'm not sure
what he saw but that's a pretty good
outcome right there
soaring in candidate for our fight of
the game Simmons
we've added by Darren grey warden
windmill Duncan
Gordon flight of the game brought to you
by the Orlando International Airport had
a feeling this might be a cannon
[Music]
augustin the foots down low though Aaron
Gordon and the foul on the Thunder edit
to balance the two all-stars and a guy
like basket II put it in and a foul on
Oklahoma City all the contact and even
though you can't see it - just trying to
get it up on the glass I shoot a lot of
free throws
warning shooting for three the foul on
Gibson Agee has been in this situation
before
to cut him off but using that bigger
body able to ceiling
[Applause]
in Orlando in the post we run the office
good things happen
bad defensive play Jonathan Isaac Gautam
get that lob and that the lappet beats
their hand that finds an open to Aaron
Gordon and she seems to be feeling good
picked up by Burch Ross is guarding Alex
Whelan not tonight have any of it and
then you're in Gordon great help from
and Rick Williams attacking Gordo within
a flexion of the steel here comes Gordon
he'll throw it down we're just coming
out of the locker room with great
intensity low pass Nixon ahead to Porter
[Applause]
get the block on marking it
[Applause]
perks came flying through he lost it
taken by bucho [ __ ] more than breaking
ahead of the pack
the stove shoots it ahead to four days
he's ahead of the pack so is Gordon so
athletic the ability to kenshin finished
Augustine looking for an opening
Gordon shoots Augustin at the
penetration dribble Gordon with that
great leaping ability able to shoot over
the top of draymond Green to break their
hello for it
careless that time Collison didn't make
a mistake make a recovery
our daddy came back made a great play by
palace' watch this rejection by aging
[Music]
this is just a great job you never give
up plenty of time for the magic
more than four bridge he drills it and
that beats the buzzer
[Music]
the phallus on Justin Jackson how's your
memory you feeling pretty good you look
lucky right now or anything tear offs to
the paint attacking the rim here in the
for that lead now back up to eight per
tour of Memphis feel like it's Toronto
with all these former rafters up Aaron
Gordon gets to back for the magic Randle
his plays line through the hands of
Parker stolen by Gordon the one who runs
with him
Aaron gives it up and a one two throws
in ham shot clock down to five more than
the to cut attempt he got it beating the
buzzer by a hair warden steps it any
feet a leg off the dribble
from behind Mormon 48 ahead of the pack
[Applause]
Isaac now spots in a jam by Jay I slowed
it up keeping knocks on his back Rasta
Gordon Aaron on the attack one stride
through the middle tortoise driving down
the middle leaves it in just pan enough
momentum to carry the lip of the rim but
a beautiful drive by AG that's pretty
impressive as well I like that you
putting yourself out there yeah the real
knock down another triple there to keep
this magics hope alive here with under a
minute left in the quarter leaving his
way through point knocks it back and
he's headed to the free-throw line and
had this kind of change his new plan
once he got to the rim they haven't done
that enough here in this in this game
when clock down to 3 here's Gordon
that's a deep smooth in the corner 80
Hicks let's check in with Jared we've
been active on both ends and impressive
[Applause]
Allen Gordon put me together again for
himself all Casteel continuity
did you see the defensive transition
officer over on that play that's an
example that's what you call
championship basketball what's up you
guys this Taylor Brooks with bleacher
report make sure that you subscribe for
some more video content